We have been speculating about the future
of the Trump family with regard to vaccination.
I'm sorry.
With regard to investigation, my mind is still
on covid once Donald Trump is no longer president
of the United States.
And we got some news that might be a sort
of signal about what we are to expect once
Donald Trump is out of office.
And that's that.
A state judge ruled yesterday that the Trump
organization must turn over documents related
to a property whose tax abatements are being
investigated by the New York attorney general
and and will continue to be investigated.
And these are this is still going on.
These are documents that the Trump organization,
this is Trump's business, previously claimed
were protected by attorney client privilege.
And a judge has decided that that is not the
case.
The attorney general argued these documents
are not privileged, partially because the
Trump organization waived privilege when it
disclosed certain documents to the IRS to
gain benefit.
And a judge agreed.
And we've heard this story before and many
will say, hasn't this been ordered before?
And they still haven't turned over the documents.
And that is true.
So what is the difference?
Why do we care about this?
We care about this for for really two primary
reasons.
No.
One, soon Donald Trump is no longer going
to be president.
And while it wasn't a big part of this case,
there are all sorts of other investigations
going on into Donald Trump and his business
and his finances and his family's finances.
And Donald Trump is soon not going to be able
to hide behind.
I'm the president and this is a burden because
I am the president.
That's something his lawyers have frequently
used to try to make the case that he should
be left alone and they've done it to some
degree of success.
That opportunity goes away in thirty five
days.
I believe it is.
And that's going to change this dramatically.
No, to the legal fees are going to become
outrageous even for Trump.
And not only is Donald Trump, I mean, listen,
he can keep trying to raise money for for
legal fees on the basis of, I don't know,
running.
And maybe that's why he'll announce that he's
running in twenty, twenty four to be able
to raise money, which he could maybe legally,
maybe not redirect to to legal fees, even
if that's a violation of campaign finance
law.
We don't that's not clear yet.
But we have this we have rumors that Donald
Trump is absolutely horrified about the possibility
of being deposed in the sexual assault case
brought by Jean Carroll.
If that name rings a bell, it should, because
we talked about her in 2016 and 2017 that
was on hold while Donald Trump was president.
He will soon not be president.
Every indication that that story and that
case is going to come back in.
And Donald Trump reportedly horrified about
maybe being deposed in that case.
And these legal fees are going to build as
the legal protections for Trump as president
evaporate.
And that could dramatically encumber Trump
over the next, who knows how many years.
So this could all get really wild in the six
to 12 months after Donald Trump leaves office,
we talked about starting to see the light
at the end of the tunnel.
As far as the pandemic is concerned, I'm starting
to see the light at the end of the tunnel
in terms of the Trump administration and its.
Going to be a bad couple of months in terms
of the virus, it's going to be a chaotic couple
of months in terms of the MAGGA people and
the cure Nonas having to adjust to this reality
of Joe Biden as president.
There's the possibility of violence.
We can never get back the lives lost due to
Trump's mishandling of the virus, et cetera,
et cetera.
But if you zoom out a little bit, vaccination
has started.
Trump is leaving.
Joe Biden is coming in.
We have early voting starting in Georgia with
Democrats still possibly taking the Senate.
And the investigations into Donald Trump are
starting with numerous now favorable decisions
by judges.
Now, will they ever get the documents that
the judge said have to be turned over?
Maybe.
And the truth is that these particular documents
like this isn't really even the bombshell
case.
The point here is at some point, Trump is
going to run out of appeals and or run out
of run out of money for appeals in terms of
legal fees.
And if and when that happens, and I believe
it's more a matter of when rather than if
this is going to become a very complicated
twenty twenty one for Donald Trump.
Very quickly, make sure you're following me
on Twitter, where you can find me at De Pakman.
We're going to take a quick break.
And it's really a packed show today.
Let's actually keep a record of this one,
because this one, I think, is going to be
pretty good.